hello i am jakin i am a nurse
at chirec on the saint anne saint
remy anderlecht site the pandemic has made my
work more difficult because already 2
1 i had to change departments i
usually work in rehabilitation
and there i am assigned to the department that  to the
vacuum
the reorganization of work learning to
work with other members of
staff that we are not
always used to the
heavy hygiene procedures to respect the stress and the
fear of this virus permanently my
expectation is  to continue to do my
work in good conditions
that we are given the means to
work properly because I like
my work and I intend to
continue people can help us of
course the population because we
are all links in  a chain therefore
to respect the instructions to respect
the hygiene rules to continue to
stay at home and we will defeat
this virus I am sure all together
united against the coronavirus